making his seventh start of the year
still looking for his first win macy
paul to young
and moscow picks him apart beautiful
quick work brad miller now two outs
goldschmidt on at first
strike three call after half inning
cardinals nothing the pirates coming to
bat
seven starts this season for
right-hander jack flaherty record of
three and two five and a half the era
adam frazier left-handed banner and a
swing and a miss and the first strikeout
for jack flaherty colin moran got off to
a very good start five home runs drove
in seven in his first eight games
a swing and a miss a slider that was
tight down and in and moran was
completely fooled it's tyler o'neill a
189 batting average
quick work
three strikeouts for musgrove already he
has great breaking stuff i mean the
curveball even that one that that he
left up
still tough to hit they'll face
carpenter
oh
it's a good day to pitch
fourth strikeout for musgrove two
looking so far thanks to ed hickox and
jack has to be jack for the cardinals to
do anything good pitch right there
that's three strikeouts in a row in his
third of the afternoon just dropped the
big breaking ball in there on bell
here's gonzales
[Applause]
is this is taken out to deep right and a
nice play made by williams up against
the wall
gregory polanco
swing and a miss a slider down and in
strikes out polanco
four strikeouts for flaherty
so now big joe's gonna have to work a
little bit with that lead off double
justin williams now to the plate
swing and a miss
fastball headed past justin williams
strikeout number five for muskrobe
one out in the third brings up tommy
edmond
carlson at
second and a swing and a miss he struck
him out six kicks
about that strikeout pitch going pirates
trying to score first
and he did
that's deep enough
carlson
that's going to be way late reynolds in
standing sac fly for colin moran bucks
on top one nothing jack into his wind-up
and the pitch and there's a fastball
strike three on the outside corner he
gets bell the for the second time and
that is now five strikeouts for flaherty
now to the top of the batting order and
tommy edmond swing and a miss
strikeout number nine season high for
joe musgrove
flaherty is struck out five
runner at first and a 2-2 pitch
fastball struck him out
the one-two
and a strikeout of osuna seven
today for jack flaherty
riddle back in left-handed batter
gonzalez runs the pitch a fastball swung
out and missed he got riddled
and struck out the side that's eight
strikeouts for flaherty with one wall
australia struck out nine matching his
career high
muscle with a new career high he's got
10 strikeouts was that impressive and uh
tried to go up 3-1 pitch
and goldschmidt hits it out to deep left
field at the wall and it's a one-hopper
over the wall and a ground rule double
there's the payoff
he struck him out
11 strikeouts came back from being down
three on the count to tyler o'neil
after five and a half pirates one
cardinals nothing lead off walk top of
the order now and brian reynolds and the
2-2 pitch
and a strikeout number nine today
to add to the season high for jack
flaherty let's see what happens here
with flaherty leaning in reading signs
holding the ball to his back
got him with the slider that's ten
strikeouts on two and two runner at
first two outs the pitch on the way a
swing and a miss he struck him out 11
strikeouts
for flaherty matching the 11 for joe
musgrove through six
eric holland is the new pitcher so the
cardinals get the lead off man aboard
but now yadier molina the 2-2
and yachty hits it down the left field
line
is it gone it is gone
yadier molina two run homer
saint louis needed it yani delivered
well here we go carpenter started off
with a single the other way
yachty gets a slider down and in and
jumps all over this bad boy the
cardinals one out away from taking four
out of five which is what they needed to
do at the start of this series
swag and a miss miller gets the
strikeout the cardinals win it two to
one they take four or five in pittsburgh
cardinals had a job to do in this series